as seasons change our everyday must have
products should too let's check in with
lifestyle expert paul zahn who's got a
look at this year's spring essentials
thanks to taylormade productions the
sponsors of this segment
that's right i got you guys covered for
all things spring let's start with skin
care for spring with olay regenerous
vitamin c plus peptide 24 hydrating
moisturizer so what this is going to do
this is going to brighten dull skin it's
going to correct the look of uneven
tones and with 24-hour moisture this is
going to hydrate your skin better than
some of those 400 creams on the market
has some wonderful dermatologists
recommended ingredients like vitamin c
b3 aha lactic acid this is really going
to give you that wonderful jlo global
spring so for more information go to
olay.com
now let's talk about fashion for the
guys with this wonderful new line mutual
weave exclusively available at jcpenney
so this is a thoughtfully designed denim
lifestyle brand that really keeps every
guy in mind has something for everyone
they have a wide variety of sizes they
have adaptive items and they have
everything from you know on trend items
to timeless pieces i'm obsessed with
this denim jacket right here they have
blue jeans these green cargo pants are
also amazing available at
jcpenney.com speaking of green
we need a signature cocktail for st
patrick's day which is right around the
corner and i have the perfect drink for
you with an irish coffee made with
mozart white chocolate vanilla cream so
this is made with the finest chocolate
from belgium it has a light texture
notes of vanilla and caramel and it has
a wonderful silky finish with some rich
acoco so this makes for the perfect
irish coffee but you can also drink some
of this mozart liqueur on the rocks or
just mix it with some vodka for our
vodka martini we also have the mozart
chocolate coffee which is also delicious
so you can order these on reservebar.com
or put it in your drizzly order and they
can deliver it right to your doorstep
now that we have the drinks the fashion
and some skincare we have some cbd that
is usda certified organic and it is farm
to shelf with our green gorilla organics
so these use zero pesticides zero toxic
chemicals and there's an entire line
with really something for everyone this
is gonna help with your sleep with
recovery for all those athletes out
there i love this body lotion after a
workout to help ease the body and help
you recover also they have stuff for
immense emotional well-being with some
of these gummies these help me sometimes
to sleep at night we also have some skin
care because cbd is going to help with
decreasing the the
wrinkling and the signs of aging and
last but certainly not least green
gorilla organics has items for you are
four-legged friends like my puppy my
puppy sometimes can't sleep
green gorilla organics has something to
help my four-legged friend so
i think i got you guys covered for
spring must-haves what do you think